welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a reaction to the
latest trailer for marvel's moon knight
coming to disney plus on march 30th
starring oscar isaac as moon knight aka
steven grant jake lockley mark spector
the superhero vigilante suffering from
dissociative identity disorder i'm so
freaking pumped for this show the way
it's gonna drag the mcu into the horror
realm so i'm gonna react to this spot go
through some highlights and then
probably break it down frame by frame in
another video coming later this week
let's react to this here we
the laws of justice tattoo
whoa seen a lot more of ether and ethan
hawk here
whoa where is this setting
okay so
holy [ __ ] wow so in the previous trailer
we learned that ethan hawk is playing a
character named arthur harrow who's a
really obscure a one-off villain from
the moon knight comics back from the 80s
but ethan hawk's a big name and he's got
a lot of powers that arthur harrow and
the comics didn't really have in this
case he looks like a cult leader he said
he based the character on david koresh
and he seems to have a similar
supernatural power base as moon knight
has he understands the voices that are
in steven grant slash mark spector's
head we may find out that ethan hawke is
not exactly arthur harrow that could be
a cover name for who he really is
i don't know about that i think ethan
hawk would be a great mephisto i don't
know if that's who he's going to be in
this show but if we are delving into the
horror side of the mcu why not
characters like dracula dracula being an
immortal vampire been around a long time
there's a lot more egyptian iconography
in this trailer in fact we see one of
the three great pyramids outside giza
with a blinding blast of purple
lightning emitting out the top of it
anytime we see this kind of purple magic
our minds go places right whether it's
the purple cracks of reality that we saw
on spider-man no way home or i think
more likely the sorcery of act of the
harkness purple magic being a kind of
dark dimension energy right and mark
specter as a kind of grave robber
archaeologist mercenary whatever he's
doing in that tomb has tapped in to that
same kind of dark magic and in this case
it's going to take the form of konchu
the egyptian moon deity who stalks him
but yes folks the day has finally come
when i can say mephisto confirmed on a
shirt because her merch partners at epic
hero shop have two new shirts inspired
by marvel's most demonic super villain
the devil's in the details with these
two new tees this crossword style shirt
is after my own heart with its mini
mephisto word clues just sitting there
in plain sight and the other shirt is
styled like a heavy metal album cover
which is the perfect theme for the
master of malice by one or both of these
bad boys and fully embrace the dark side
of the mcu plus when he does show up in
a film or a tv series and he will you
will already have the gear and be ready
to go epic hero has all kinds of cool
merch inspired by all of your favorite
properties and they're always on top of
the latest trends and memes coming out
of the shows and movies like you better
believe they put out a ned as sorcerer's
supreme t-shirt as soon as no way home
came out so sign up for their newsletter
at the bottom of their website to get
notified about the latest merch drops
and check out all of their incredible
products at epicheroshop.com
be your own hero i mean the visuals of
this show the cinematography might be
what i'm most excited about like this
shot of oscar isaac in this meadow with
conscious mummified form behind him just
it all looks like it's shot on planes
like he's not really in that meadow he's
on a green screen set konchu looks like
he was vexed in behind him no one is
actually where they feel like they
should be it's a very spooky unsettling
image to be honest with you now another
new shot in this shows another pyramid
that is placed randomly beside what
looks like a wren fair style jousting
ring this pyramid looks completely out
of place with this setting almost like
it suddenly just appeared out of nowhere
doctor who style it also might remind
you of the fact that we just saw renfer
in loki that a time door is randomly
showing up in is this going to have some
crossovers with that that'd be pretty
exciting to see i'm wondering what we
should make of this tattoo on arthur
harrow's arm that just showed the scales
of justice seesawing back and forth why
does he have this tattoo what's the
significance of that well if you look
closely both those scales are being
dangled from the mouths of crocodiles an
important part of egyptian mythology
there's the egyptian deity of sobek who
has the head of a crocodile who's
associated with the protection of
dangers from the nile a symbol of
military power but in this case it's
being linked with justice so ultimately
i think the way this is gonna go down is
that we're gonna start with mark spector
an archaeologist who goes on these
missions who gets imbued with the power
of the egyptian moon deity konchu that
leaves him in this broken state to where
he no longer remembers that past ends up
working in a museum as steven grant and
then finally awakens back to that past i
love how violent this show looks like
it's gonna be kevin feige said that
normally marvel superheroes eventually
start pulling their punches but not in
this case it just keeps wailing away and
wailing away we're gonna go to some very
dark places in this show i can't wait to
talk about this more on the channel so
again check out our merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at avos follow the
new rockstars and subscribe to rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you